[MUSIC]
We are now ready to learn how dynamic
programming algorithms
work for finding optimal paths
in the graphs.
Let's start from this graph.
And let's try to figure out how to move in
this graph
to reach their sink with the maximum
number of attractions.
At every step, there are only two
decisions to make.
Either to move vertically or move
horizontally,
south or east.
So, to arrive to the final destination we
can either arrive by moving south or
moving east.
And let's define a variable, which is
SouthOrEast(i,j) as the length of
the longest path from the initial node
node (0,0) to node (i,j) in the grid.
And, of course, we can immediately write a
simple recursive program for
computing south or east for (n,m),
for the final destination vertex.
It is simply the minimum of
SouthOrEast of (n-1,m)
plus the weight of the vertical edge into the
final node.
Or SouthOrEast(n,m-1) +
weight of horizontal edge
into the final node.
And as soon as we analyzed it, there
is a very simple recursive algorithm for
computing the optimal path.
To node (i,j) and the algorithm is called
SouthOrEast
and the only thing this algorithm does,
is to compute
alternatives between two scenarios.
Moving to node (i,j) using the vertical edge or
using to node (i,j) using the horizontal edge.
Using this algorithm will solve our problem.
If you watch me when I explain the change
problem, you will figure out
that this algorithm, while being
correct, will take enormous time to finish.
Because we will be making recursive
calls many, many times, for a fixed value
of i and j.
And therefore, we need to come up with
something better, and let's try
to apply the dynamic program idea
for traveling in this grid.
Well, the optimal pass to reach node
zero, of course
we will see only zero attractions, so the
score in this node will be zero
The score in this node will be 1 because
there is only one way to reach this node by
moving vertically.
The optimal score to reach this node will
be 5,
which is 1 plus 4, because there is no
other alternative.
And as a result, we can compute all values
we described the lengths of the longest path.
For the first row and the first column on
this graph.
Now something interesting starts.
What is the best way to reach this node in
the graph, the node (1,1).
Should we move to this node using
horizontal or vertical?
South or east?
Well, if we move
horizontally into this node, then the
length of the path will be 1 plus 3,
and if we move vertically, the length of
the path will be 3 plus 0.
Of course, we choose to move horizontally,
because 1 plus 3 is larger than 3 plus 0.
And we know afterwards that
the optimal path to this node has length 4.
And for the future, we represent the edge
horizontal edge that we use, to
reach this node,
as the bold edge, and we will see later why
it is important.
How about this edge?
The same argument, and we decide to move
to this node
by using a vertical edge in this case.
And we'll continue further and further.
Let us try one more time.
What about this node?
How should we arrive to this node?
In this case we compare, 4 plus 2
with 5 plus 2.
5 plus 2 is larger than 4 plus 2
and therefore, we choose to arrive to this
node
by moving along vertical edge.
Therefore, the recurrence for computing
the longest paths is the following.
We define S(i,j) as the length of the
longest path
from the initial node to (i,j),
and S(i,j) is simply
the maximum of S(i-1,j) + the weight
of the vertical edge
or S(i,j-1) + the weight of
the horizontal edge.
And after we finish this, then in the
programming procedure, we will
fill the value of longest paths
for every node and we'll learn that
the optimal path to the final destination
has length 34.
When we are doing this, please note that
in some cases, instead
of making decision South or East, we will
make a decision South and East.
For example, in this particular node, we
are comparing
22 plus 0, which is equal to 20 plus 2.
Which means that both
horizontal and vertical edges entering into
this vertex are in bold.
And now, I hope it will become clear
why we were retaining information about
both edges.
Because 34, the number in the last node,
tells us the length of the longest path.
But it doesn't tell us how this longest
path was traversing the graph.
But with both edges, we can figure out because
we know that we arrive to the last
node marked by 34 by moving along
a horizontal bold edge, here it is.
We arrive in the node labeled by 32.
Once again, by moving by horizontal edge,
and we arrive
to this node labeled by 30 by moving along
a vertical edge.
We continue backtracking in this way, and
sooner or later, we will arrive
in the initial node, and the blue path
shown on the slide is actually
an optimal path from the initial to the final
destination in this graph.
And we now move from describing how
dynamic programming works in a simple
Manhattan grid
to describing how it works
in arbitrary alignment graphs.